[Music]
so
uh i want i like to check out sometimes
what like fellow youtubers are doing
okay and um
because she's trying to just ruin every
kind of youtube community and this one
to be fair was already ruined
so remember uh we were covered we
covered this a couple years ago the
whole van life movement
yeah youtubers that just basically
turn a van into a home and then they
have perfect internet from there
and they stream about living in like you
know
on the go and making the little homemade
showers
well another makeups meticulous usually
and their clothes look fine and you're
like there's no way you're living in a
van
right right your clothes don't even have
wrinkles correct
well uh brie larson
is as you can see by the title of this
joining the van life movement
she's good i hope it's in front of one
it's not so she's joining it
uh brought to you by nissan nissan gave
her a van
oh just like all you know like all these
other young creators starting out
yeah they just get a fan
cool she is i still don't know how to do
it she's aging very poorly
not only very poorly she yeah she's just
falling apart man like a banana yeah
you know you got to put her in the
freezer soon otherwise it's going to go
for it
these intros hello youtube so here we
are with another video
and no it is not an announcement that i
have joined
the cottage core movement even though i
am a fan
what is what is cottage core are those
fans of the cheese and
whoever oh god dude leave that pause for
us
of course i would love to look at the
eyes
she looks like jim carrey's mask
somebody stop man she's starting to look
like eric stoltz's mask
she's getting there looking good
look this was captain marvel right this
was a famous actress this was a chick
who was
if we're being fair kind of hot in that
what was that terrible movie that
ruined all this generation of women uh
scott pilgrim
she was pretty good-looking in that yeah
for a moment yeah
this is if i woke up
me being and i'm trying to say because i
know people are going to go mercek look
he's too good for
i'm saying me knowing very well what i'm
bringing to the table
if i woke up next to this i wouldn't i
would be unhappy
how old is she frozen this is to say
that i
want to say no
okay hold on what's cottage hold on
that's more important what's cottage
core
okay so cottage core is an aesthetic
above
all like what grunge was in the 90s
apparently
it's centered around what you would
imagine living in a cottage or
in the countryside would be like so i'm
sorry
living in middle america is now a cool
hipster thing
yes that's what cottage core is right
living in middle america
is drinking it like out of quirky mason
jars is that cottage core
okay so here's the here's the tag line
your grandma
but like hip
i had to stop myself no i know i was
about to say the minecraft phrase
because i'm just
[Music]
how about alt f4 yourself there you go
uh she's throwing it i'll go back to you
she's 31. 31
31 yeah
[Music]
like cottage core like i'm telling you
man average dudes could wake up next to
brie larson and go i could do better
than this
well because it's not even the way she
looks right because whatever
it's it's also that she's insufferable
that you would have to like
talk to her so cottage core let me
explain what cottage core is okay
cottage core is the lefty hipsters
taking over trad life you know you know
a lot of the trad life memes like here's
a picture
new york times have of cottage core it's
basically tread life
oh they're trying to do the chat thing
but without all the chat stuff right
right right i found the same picture
yeah that's that's the thing that that's
cottage court so they like all the old
dresses and the
and the and the and the giant bread bask
the picnic baskets
but they want to have like you know
abortions and
support black lives matter got it yes
yes i don't know if you know this but
places that have cottages didn't have
planned parenthoods
okay sorry van life she's coming our
culture is not your costume lefties
she's coming thinking about all the
money that nissan gave her for this
i want to be part of van life i'm coming
for you van life
i see what you're doing online and i'm
going to destroy you like i've destroyed
every other youtuber i thought you were
a game streamer
she doesn't realize that what are you
she she doesn't realize that like she's
doing what the biden thing like where
she's
trying to be cute and say something but
by saying you're actually exposing the
real
the real motivation here just as a
comparison taylor swift is also 31.
oh my god and she's just so you can
compare [ __ ] she looks fantastic
yes horrible person but of course
outstandingly attractive
how old's the well the grizzly girl's
probably young uh the chris
uh what what's probably like 24 hours
like 20
25 26 yeah she's young okay okay
because i could pull a picture of her
because grizzly girl's got you beat
brick could we just a just a fresh
like you know absolutely it's like when
you go to a wine tasting and they give
you coffee beans to smell
it's in between it's a palette it's to
cleanse the palette
uh yeah sure and uh let's see which one
okay let's do the one that you the
i like the one where she's with her
parents because she actually gets a good
angle that's a good one this one's not a
bad one either though
yeah that's uh that's her there that's
right
clean it up and this is her almost
wearing the same kind of shirt so we
could really compare it like you know
side by side yeah there we go that's
that's a nice
little thank you chrisley daughter that
is a palette cleanser if i've ever seen
one but you know what the sucky part
about it is
we got to go back you got to go back oh
i was wrong 24
22 24. okay that's about right that's
what that's the sweet spot yeah that's
what i thought
that's the sweet spot bro 24 stream
and i want in so the incredible people
at nissan
have gifted me a van the incredible
people at nissan have gifted the event i
want to show you something
thanks to nissan for this amazing van
and partnership although this video is
not sponsored
they've given you a van and you're
saying it's a partnership
what do you mean this video is not
sponsored because it's partnered they're
partners
do you know why it's there she's saying
it's not sponsored because if your video
was sponsored
you cannot monetize your video yes
and i will be working to build it into
the van
of my dreams you you won't you're going
to have a bunch of mexicans do it for
you
we're talking comfortable mattress
we're talking incredible kitchen with
like
pink countertops we're talking disco
ball we're talking
projector watch movies outside she's so
hateable because she's not
she just isn't anything you know
there you go
now she's like i got a 23 skadoo out of
here now she's the quirky girl from
from the from your job yeah that's like
where are always trying to be funny and
you're like
stop stop it she's always quoting
jillian from workaholics
[ __ ] stop i know people like
that um
this is this is she's so hateable and
she's also just she's not anything
she's just waiting on another picture
from uh cottage core
in uh show links okay can you find us a
picture of the grizzly daughter doing
cottage core
i don't think that's oh my god so this
is hipsters okay so
this is hipsters taking over cottage
core i can already tell by this
you're gonna hate it
this isn't yours go back to your go back
to brooklyn
leave these people alone
all right sorry let's get back here
i see it's the lens hmm
[Music]
okay sounds great thank you so much i
can't wait on the call with nissan
it's not a sponsored video keep that in
mind it's important wait what's not a
spot who's not a sponsor
nissan is not a sponsor ah damn it
joke's on you we can't monetize anyway
okay so they told me to go [ __ ]
myself great would that be they said oh
my god i'm super annoying
she's like so toyotas now oh my god they
just told me they gave the van to jeremy
renner instead
because he needs to live in it they
[Music]
he said he needs it more than me
it's life or death for jeremy renner
[Laughter]
stupid [ __ ] dumb fans
oh [ __ ] jeremy ryder she's out there
with a big beard like uh
yes ever since my wife kicked me out and
accused me all that stuff
it's really it's getting real weird
that was that i guess what i'm what i've
learned from this is that
i'm really wholly unlikable you think
bigger
which is one of my favorite things i
feel like i'm a pretty big thinker
and mike
[ __ ] nissan the key is a far superior
machine
she's a pretty big thinker is she what
i've learned from this
is that i need to think bigger which is
one of my favorite things i feel like
i'm a pretty big thinker
and whenever i meet people who uh
i guess it's thicker the new cool way of
saying nobody
who's a big thinker thinks they're a big
thing of course not
can think bigger than i can i get super
excited so now i'm kind of
hmm what other crazy things can i
put in this i hope that's a [ __ ] god
go ahead
go ahead if it's a [ __ ] car that's
what i was gonna go with
was there similar or she's no longer
talking about the van she's talking
about her [ __ ]
adam and eve is my new sponsor
trying to think how many things i can
put in it i don't know the fans
would be cool can we watch you
can we watch brie lauren dude brie
larson could turn this around if she
drives that van up into her own
she'll be a [ __ ] legend well the
harlem globetrotters have to get out
first
to make room so i tried to find
an attractive photo of brie larson and i
put
like hot reelers and this is what came
up okay
uh right down there you just type in
brie larson scott pilgrim
hot b larson okay not bad but like why
does she have a sweater review frozen
i don't know i'm not bad but very guys
pandas aren't real not bad but very
featureless
yeah she's like the equivalent of like
this this brie larson's like
a kind of cute girlfriend can i cleanse
the palette for you though sure
now we're talking baby yes yes
yes grizzly daughter always wins i don't
even know her [ __ ] name i should
probably look her name up uh savannah
grip
there we go savannah chrisley is this
that's the one right there man
that's a bad right there that's good
jeans
well the dad you know okay sorry let's
go back to this
frumpy looking frumpy-looking marvel
character
could we can we remake captain marvel
with savannah chrisley
oh god yes i'm all for it i don't know
if she could act but it doesn't matter
i'm here to save you from the bad guys
y'all
i'm gonna save you with the power of
prayer let's all pray and then you're
like everyone's taking me
this movie does suck too
hmm what other crazy things can i
put in this i guess i'm gonna have to
like look around my house and kind of go
about my day and figure out like what
is it that i love and what do i want to
take with me on
the road
oh on the road so this isn't van life
because these van
the real van life people before it got
famous the people that actually
did this early on where people actually
actually live in events
they don't have a home to go to they
don't get to go home at the end of it
somebody literally should [ __ ] follow
that van
not bother her or anything i i want a
complete breakdown of how much time she
spends
in that van yeah she's gonna be staying
more at four season hotel rooms
and i know people are thinking oh you
don't want to say that because then
people could go harass her no
i'm saying keep eyes on the van i bet
you brie larson will be nowhere near
that goddamn van
most of the day trust me i'm not saying
people should follow b
larson because i'm saying she very much
won't have anything to do with that fan
so this is her work walking into the
people that are going to redo the video
brought to you by vfx
tell me about what you do here
okay first off why is she dressed like
she's like she's in belle biv devoe
i need to know what's up with her she's
dressed
jean 80s jeans look she's dressing from
the elliot page collection
oh she's a white guy and also i love the
passionless like
so like tell me what you do
she wants nothing to do with this if you
guys want an idea of like how to
take what she's doing and contrast it to
somebody
to who's always enjoying himself i
always like to use as an example and
this is a guy i've always
liked guy fieri guy fieri is just one of
those likable guys
he's you never watch a guy fieri show
and go
man this guy's a real miserable [ __ ] he
he really hates his job like
you get guy fieri in some shitty diner
in indiana and he's sitting there for an
hour
so how do you make these tater tots
anyway man they chase charlie like he's
really into it
he's having fun he's throwing tater tots
around at people everybody's having a
good time
like if you're not you can't just go hey
we'll give this celebrity money
and they'll just get all these views
people aren't gonna resonate with the
content
if you're not happy to be there it's
true because guy fiat is one of those
like everyone became
every he became a joke with the whole
flavor town stuff but ask yourself
honestly who would you rather have a
beer with guy fieri or [ __ ] brie
larson
guy fieri all day right like you know he
probably beat out like
legitimately good options yeah cause
first time he's gonna go the best place
in town
he's gonna know the place goes dude this
place has one dollar beers and the best
burger you'll ever have
yeah he's a guy guy fairy's the kind of
guy that if you're hanging out with him
in vegas you'd be like yo let's go eat
at your restaurant he's like nah man we
gotta go off the path man i'm going to
show you this place that makes burgers
but it's like out in the desert
okay and it's the best ever had the best
burger ever had i actually tried to
steal a lot from these guys
so this is vehicle effects and we do a
lot of the
so okay a question why is danny policek
doing this
danny what do you need this job cars for
movies are everything from
fast and furious to the batmobiles we do
a lot of different stuff wow
those are movies i know of it's a pretty
diverse shop
and there's a lot of a high degree of
technical skill
and it's really interesting he's like so
tell me what you do around here and he's
like i don't know i mean i guess a lot
of the writing and then letting ryan
long take credit because he's
good-looking
[Laughter]
another classic oh rotten long attack
take that right take that take it you
down a peg
mr fox news mr culture warrior oh
culture warrior right alone loves when
you call him that yeah repeat it he
really loves it he loves to be
a culture warrior ryan he likes when you
thank him for his service
hey can you hear while you're at it can
you install an ass on her
because that would be amazing oh my god
i'm sorry i thought that was one of the
guys that worked
in the van company mexico i thought it
was a mexican guy
no i don't know you know you put
countertop in a bang
she's gorgeous is she
she looks like she looks like something
you drop old people and [ __ ]
wheelchair-bound handicaps in right like
oh she looks like she it looks like
she's about to deliver my amazon
packages
what no they only use mercedes which is
weird yeah i know yeah
[Applause]
step one i like all the blueprints like
she's the one that came up with them
yeah she's sitting here going what are
we gonna do
here that would be like me just walking
up while they're
about to do a space launch and just
rolling blueprints out and going
um that almost feels like an eric andre
sketch
him just rolling out blue prince oh now
what are we going to do here with the
sir who are you get the [ __ ] out of here
you need a lead you're going to go to
jail you're going to go to federal
prison if you don't leave sir
okay sorry is to insulate
both for sound and temperature for sound
your windows are going to be up here
basically what we'll do is we'll frame
all of this
i wonder that guy's from philadelphia
now before we start cutting it up
and then we'll use that additional let
me ask you a question bree don't you
have
one of them guys goes hey like don't you
have a house
oh god so her van is gonna basically be
like a coffin for her career
yes go check out the camper van
yes this has been months in the making a
lot of conversations
a lot of overthinking i just as you know
the ratio has to be a lie
right like you don't buy do you really
buy 4k up 57
down i don't buy that no
i'm terrible at making decisions of this
kind has been quite a bit of back and
forth
but here we are so headed there now
gonna check it out
so has youtube just given up on vandus
owens now
yeah you know we haven't heard anything
from her
whatever what was i forget what her real
name was what was vanda
owen's real name
because i don't remember i know you
don't remember any otherwise i don't
blame you
uh it was like janelle janae janae
janelle
you know something jerry jerry
is jerry miner why is she in my gta safe
house garage
yeah good question all these cars are
cool
so name them all these cars are cool i
would be like name one of them
name name that one i would just name
that what what car is that
janelle lelania there you go
like so a lot of people do
you know just like awnings attack the
last video was one month
one month ago that's weird yeah how many
views
uh over seven hundred thousand oh she's
still doing all right i guess view wise
that the ones that the views that
youtube's giving her
uh so she has an air fryer i guess and
i'm gonna skip ahead here because
i wanna see what she's gonna i wanna see
her start her van life
i'm gonna be making coffee and like
sipping it outside
you could already do that you don't need
to retrofit a van to sit on your porch
all right i'm gonna check she's a
terrible actor
hey hey so it turns out that my van blew
up
how many scenes do we need it turns out
that my van's on fire
uh it was a big it was my fault really
interim update
because by now you've seen tons of
footage of the making of it
the tons and tons of conversations about
every little detail that was going in
to this van unfortunately we had some
hiccups along the way
oh yeah what's that with kovid being in
the pandemic
it meant that things took longer you
know a normal process of bringing a team
together to build this van
which no no no no because you live in
california
because you oh god another great freeze
frame because you live in california
almost complete there are some tweaks to
be made
but it is in pretty good shape uh
i'm scared and mostly so
there's her van
[Music]
quirky now this music
what she's gorgeous she's gorgeous this
is incredible
can i just oh is she giving up her house
and then
of course she's not and she's also not
going to give the van to a homeless
person that needs it because these
[ __ ]
hollywood idiots always pretend they
care
could i um could i just say something
really quick that um
[Music]
that has nothing to do with anything oh
weird feat
sorry i want to just read a statistic
that is
wholly unrelated to this video and sure
i apologize for being off topic here
sure
but i just thought i would remind our
audience that there are 580
000 homeless people in the united states
and nissan thought good marketing would
be to
give a van not even to a [ __ ]
entitled celebrity which is one thing
but to give one who's universally
despised like i could find a nicer
homeless person right now
she whose life would be eternally
changed by that van
she didn't pay for it either because you
saw nissan calling her
the people that redid the van did didn't
charge her for it it's all for publicity
she didn't have to do anything other
than be a [ __ ] imagine if you knew
like a streamer right like let's say
there was like a streamer who
who uh wanted to do the whole van thing
whatever
and they had a van that was just just
beat to [ __ ] and falling apart right and
they were basically like borderline
homeless but a good dude
imagine giving them this van how much it
would change their game
they'd be like holy [ __ ] this is like a
mobile command center they'd be all
grateful and happy
yeah 580 actually 581 thousand if we
round up
that's in the u.s in the u.s want to
know
because now now i'm gonna i'll do some
stats for you too want to know how many
of those people
are in california out of the hundred 580
seventy nine thousand
a hundred and seventy thousand justin we
have fifty students have to go all over
the country looking
we have you could have walked out your
door and given the van to somebody
but remember guys climate change also
kids point something out
she's one of those climate change people
uh that's a gas guzzling nissan that's
not an electric nissan
so you're gonna add your carbon
footprint
[ __ ] hater and why is your [ __ ]
pizza ramek looks so weird everything
about hers because the hammock looks
like her everything about her is [ __ ]
weird
she is really awful huh oh yeah nobody
lie who likes her
and i think that part of her becoming
ugly like over time is
also i do believe that there's some
degree of
just your your your true inner self
comes out over time and i think she's
just slowly been just
awful and now she looks awful